okay it is my 33rd birthday today we've
got a balloon here that Pat got me along
with some other things which will be
sampling on the bonus show but I'll talk
about that later I'll go into the into
it on the bonus show a little more
extensively why I went from you I used
to like my birthday to being lukewarm
about it to now absolutely really not
enjoying it one thing that I have been
doing for a couple of years on my
birthday is a huge membership special
and because when lots of people sign up
it distracts me from my birthday and
makes it not as bad in 2015 we had 19
people sign up for the birthday discount
last year on februari second 2016 we had
36 people sign up for my birthday
discount my goal this year is to beat 36
which really for us is a lot of new
members in a single day but maybe
combining my birthday discount with the
acute need for independent media in the
Trump era we can make it happen so the
coupon code will make a yearly
membership normally sixty dollars only
33 because I'm turning 33 today that's
the logic behind the discount the coupon
code is surprisingly 33 today 33 today
all one word all lower case you can pay
with a credit card debit card paypal
with whatever funding source you have
set up there or you can click mail in a
check and then you mail in a check for
33 bucks the way to do this is you go to
david pakman.com slash membership you
click on yearly so that you're looking
at the yearly prices sixty dollars a
year will be selected by default click
on the red sign up button and then on
the next page you'll see a coupon code
field you can type in 33 today again the
number 33 today all lowercase all one
word 33 today and the best thing about
this is you can keep the discounted
price as long as your membership stays
active you're locking in the discount do
it here's the 36 plus we're targeting 37
birthday memberships I think we can do
it and happy birthday we mentioned yes
uh yeah okay well so anyway more
discussion of the birthday stuff on the
bonus show today david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code
30-3 today it will give you a huge
discount down to only thirty-three
dollars a year for full David Pakman
show membership